Speaker 1: OK. We have really substantive
follow up to a major story from either last
week or the week before, not too long ago,
you might remember that I reported to you
that two prosecutors working on the Manhattan
District Attorney's Criminal Probe of Donald
Trump's organization resigned. They just they
said, we quit. We're not doing it anymore,
and we went that story. This was from
OK, February 23rd, so two weeks ago.
And in this original reporting, two prosecutors
resigned. This was a years old probe.
We didn't know why. We, as far as was
announced, the investigation was still ongoing
and it was sort of a real question mark. And at
the time, my speculation remember speculation was
these prosecutors realized. They're not going to
indict Trump. They're not going to charge Trump.
And they felt my work is being done in vain.
I'm getting the hell out of here. That was
my speculation. And I identified it as such. To
be clear, the speculation on the right was they
quit because they knew there was no evidence
against the Trump Organization and they felt they
were being railroaded into. There was no evidence
of that. There was no evidence of my hypothesis,
but I argued to you that my hypothesis is far
more plausible and my hypothesis has now been
vindicated and vindicated. Exactly. Prosecutors
resigned, says a new article after New York D.A.
said he wasn't prepared to move forward with
the indictment of Donald Trump. We now know
the reason, and I got lucky, it happened
to be the reason I said to top prosecutors
leading the criminal probe into Trump and his
business resigned after the Manhattan district
attorney said he was not prepared to authorize
an indictment against the former president,
a person familiar with the investigation said.
And there it is. Kerry Dunn and Mark Pomerantz,
two senior prosecutors on the team, resigned last
month, one day after Manhattan District Attorney
Alvin Bragg informed them he's not prepared
to move forward with criminal charges. The
resignations followed weeks of internal debate
and discussion over the strength of evidence
and whether it could pass the hurdle of proving a
crime. Now I want to be really clear it's possible
that the D.A. is correct. We don't have enough
to prove a Trump crime here. That may well be,
but the question was why would they resign?
Would they resign? Because there's nothing
here to investigate. Doesn't seem likely because
they've been investigating for a long time. If
that was the reason they would have known, there
was no evidence a long time ago. Or is it more
likely that they were getting frustrated with the
fact that they've been investigating for so long?
They have what they might see as a solid case
built up. And yet no one is willing to indict.
And that appears to be it. Now, interestingly,
there's some detail here about why this is
the abrupt resignation. OK, where's the section
here? Was originally started by Cy Vance. We
know that the New York Times first reported that
the resignations followed a decision by Bragg to
start presenting evidence to the grand jury. The
strength of the evidence against Trump has been
debated by attorneys in the office for months.
Some prosecutors, including the two that resigned,
believed there was sufficient evidence to charge
Trump, while others, including career prosecutors,
were skeptical they could get a conviction because
of the difficulty in proving criminal intent.
That's another thing we've talked about a lot of
the crimes here that Donald Trump could be charged
with really require you to show what his state
of mind and intent was. And that can be very,
very difficult. On the one hand, some prosecutors
believe Trump speaks with a lot of hyperbole,
but it wasn't clear that they could
show he acted with intent to defraud.
There's also a very important
piece here about Michael Cohen
and this I think we should talk about a
little more. Multiple factors were at play,
including lack of key Trump Organization insider
cooperating with insiders cooperating with the
investigation, who at trial could walk the jury
through the evidence. The possible value of using
Michael Cohen, Trump's former personal attorney,
who in testimony before Congress alleged Trump
inflated and devalued assets for his advantage,
was discussed with the team. Cohen pleaded guilty
to nine charges, including lying to Congress. He
was once close to Trump, but his conviction and
public statements critical of Trump would give
the defense ammunition to aim to discredit him.
That is a very, very interesting piece of this.
The idea is if you you don't have a cooperating
witness from inside Trump's business, you do
have all sorts of claims from Michael Cohen.
But Michael Cohen, if you read between the lines,
what they're saying is would be easy to discredit
and destroy his credibility in a cross-examination
on the basis that he has perjured himself. He has
lied. He has a long history of all of the
trouble that ultimately got him convicted.
The counter to that be. Well, those are all crimes
he committed for Donald Trump. But I think it's a
very legitimate question to say what is a jury
going to think if Michael Cohen is their main
witness and is cross-examined about all the times
that he lied? Well, so you told the lie, then
how are we to believe that you are telling the
truth now, et cetera, et cetera? So the point here
is this is number one exactly what we believe was
going on prosecutors getting sick of the fact that
they're doing their work. And nobody really seems
willing to prosecute. That seems to be going on.
And then number two, this is why I continue
to say Donald Trump is not going to spend a
single day in prison, and I apologize to people
who think I'm causing that to be the truth. No,
prosecutors are listening to me. They're going to
decide what to do, regardless of what I say. I see
it as a very high bar to reach that. A prosecutor
will say, I'm going to be the first. The first to
indict a former president. I think if one did it,
others would fall. But who is willing to be first?
We haven't found anybody quite yet. And that's the
latest with the prosecution that's in Manhattan.
There's Georgia Southern District of New York.
There's all these other things going on, but at
least as far as what's going on in Manhattan,
a logical follow up to the story from February.